The reality of mobile networking
means that the number of
file requests can be just as
significant as the size of requests.
In other words, aim to reduce
the number of image requests,
not just the size of image files.
>> We call this problem latency,
which is the delay between request and
response.
>> Yeah.
Every time your browser attempts to
retrieve an image from a website
there are potential delays
at every step of the way between your
device and the website's servers.
And every one of those delays can
vary significantly and unpredictably.
>> Behind all that is
the fundamental problem that data
can't travel any faster
than the speed of light.
>> Yeah, I mean surely Google or someone
else could do something about that.
The speed of light, you know,
it's so last century.
Cameron, like,
you're a physicist, right.
>> Stop, stop, stop, stop.
No.
>> All right.
>> Definitely not.
At least, not any time this millennium.
>> All right, whatever, whatever.
Anyway, optical fiber can only achieve a
bit better than half the speed of light.
So, at best, London to California,
return trip times for
example, are around
a hundred milliseconds.
>> And performance expert,
Ilya Grigorik,
calls latency the new bottleneck.
>> Thanks Sam.
Indeed, it turns out that for
many modern web pages, bandwidth
doesn't matter as much as latency does.
If you find that surprising,
check the instructor notes for
an explanation of why that is the case.
The bottom line is that performance
is a fundamental part of a truly
responsive design.
In practice, that means you need
to reduce the file sizes and
reduce the number of file requests.
And one great way to reduce the number
of image bytes is to compress them or
reduce the number of images.
>> Thanks Eliott.
In this lesson,
we show you lots of ways to achieve
graphical effects without image files.